[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to part 2 of the discussion about
the future of John snow that I had with
the other members of the golden company
I don't want to waste any more of your
time so let's pick up right where we
left off when John goes to Dragonstone
and he meets up with Daenerys and they
have this talk about the north then
what's going to happen is Danny gonna
choose sides with John what's John gonna
do next I think that John's gonna remind
Daenerys of her brother Rhaegar for what
she knew of him and I think that
obviously at first she is going to be
thinking about herself and she has been
thinking about herself even though she's
got a really good idea of what she wants
to do
now she's freed slaves and she's done
she's done good things but also terrible
things have happened terrible things
happen in the war
and I think she might warm up to the
idea that if there is no Iron Throne
left in the end the Knights came the
white Walker army just a ravaged lands
in winter because ice is not life right
fires technically life life in this
world so I think that she'll she can get
behind what John is saying she will I
think it will be like a thing of Destiny
where it's just an epiphany where where
her and John have a conversation is this
something that feels right and we do
know that Targaryens have prophetic
dreams or prophetic visions so for the
most part in the books we haven't seen a
lot of that in the show but a
conversation between them could have a
similar type of effect in the show it's
more visual when we see it more in their
body language and in their faces so I
think that that could happen and then
that Daenerys could really get behind
what John is saying because he's so
confident in what he believes so what
he's saying to her is he's really going
to pitch it and he's going to be like
listen this is straight up this is I'm
going to tell you everybody's going to
dive you don't help me anyways so she'll
eventually could find it do you think
she'll send any men up north yeah
definitely I think I think she has to
she won't have a choice at this point
she'll become curious like grey and
Gemma have been seeing and I think she
won't send her home for us obviously
because I think her goal right now is to
get her family seat back she definitely
wants the Iron Throne back she wants to
restore the Targaryen dynasty in
Westeros obviously that's been her goal
since season 1 and she's finally trying
to achieve that I think I think most of
us are on
remove like okay finally Daenerys is
leaving Marine we want to see this
happen but I think if you look at the
house of the undying vision really I
think it's pretty indicative that her
that her destiny is in the north right I
mean she goes beyond the wall it's very
cold when she finds rego and drove well
I think that's indicative missed her
destinies in the north so I think that
she will remember what she saw
she never touches the throne but snow is
on the throne and I know some of us
think that that that means that Jon Snow
will be on the throne I know that I
think that but I think that yeah I think
she will send someone perforce there but
her forces will be split up like you
said like Euron's probably going to
smash part of her death racket or
whatnot I think she'll be curious and
she'll have to send people up there see
I don't agree um not right away I don't
not on the whys of John alone
I think she'll listen to him and it'll
be very respectful and she'll be curious
and she'll probably think he's really
hot because let's face it Jon Snow but I
think she'll she's got that laser beam
focus on the iron throne in the way John
does with the night's king and I think
she will be ultimately unfortunately a
bit dismissive and and I think she will
say only get up that's great okay
brilliant and right now this is my focus
and this is my priority and I think
she'll turn her sights to King's Landing
and she may have a change of heart
something might prompt her but I think
initially she's not going to support
John and I think their first meeting
might not go down fabulously I agree
with secret I think she is going to wait
I think her main focus is going to be
the iron throne and the dispense me of
Cersei I also think because of some of
the leaked photos where you're on has
Yara and some of the same snakes I think
she might want to focus more on getting
them back because she has made alliances
with them and if it wasn't for them she
wouldn't be where she wouldn't be in
dragons at all so I think she needs to
get them
back or at least try to get them back or
at least show her force so I don't think
she'll be focused on what John's focus
on I think they'll be on two different
pages but I don't think she will write
him off as being crazy I think she might
just you know be like well right now I
have to do this I'll get back to you
later on that yeah I kind of agree with
that I don't think she's gonna send men
up north right away because she just got
the Dragonstone and sir she's going to
be aware of that she still has her focus
on that and she's not going to want to
leave herself open for attack or
vulnerable especially after she just
lost all those men and a big part of her
fleet at sea so if she sent then sent
men north it would kind of leave
Daenerys open for attack so is this a
scenario that we're going to get where
we're talking I can talk about spoilers
here right then where we're basically
John doesn't get the support he needs so
he goes north to catch a white and then
this is what is like Daenerys boom
here's the flogging wait you got to do
something about this now is that where
we're going to be going - well if we go
off of the evidence from this offseason
of the spoiler photos and reports and
stuff like that it does appear that
that's going to happen but I'm curious
to see what gray and secrets have to say
about this because I know they were a
bit skeptical of some of this stuff at
first what do you what do you two think
about this I do think that Daenerys is
going to want proof but if she wants
proof she should get on the back of her
dragon and take her ass north of the
wall I don't think she should I think
it's stupid to test someone with going
north of the wall and capturing a white
and bringing it back I think that
suicide mission I don't I don't see why
she just can't go and see for herself
because she has a dragon she can get
there in no time but yeah I agree I
actually said that before Daenerys could
be way up in the sky and fly up north to
where she would be out of reach and out
of harm if she did see the knight King
in his army so all she'd have to do is
do a quick fly up check it
and then come back and like you said she
could see for herself without
endangering anybody especially the king
and the [ __ ] orders right so she
does that I don't know that's a little
selfish of her but she may do I mean she
I do think though she will require proof
because she's probably never heard of
anything she's she's been in Essos her
whole life so she's probably never heard
of the others or the White Walkers it's
all foreign to her so to hear that like
I would want proof
I wouldn't necessarily task anybody was
going to get me a zombie and bring it
back to me but I would just want proof
they don't have pictures but if I had a
dragon I just do a flyover and get the
proof for myself I I don't know I think
maybe her proof could come from Jorah
and Sam Sam knows about the white Jorah
is from Westeros he's from the north
he's from bear island so he knows a lot
about them so maybe it's it's Jorah that
convinces her see this is how I've
reconciled in my mind I think if
Daenerys was the outright ask for
evidence for proof and she would be very
responsible to say the least I don't
think she will ask for proof I think
it's a decision John will make fushia
frustration and how can I convince her I
need proof I need to show her that's the
only way around this I can think I can't
see her expecting him to go and do that
like you said it's a suicide mission
and and I can't see you know she's she
could be full of her own self-importance
at the best of times but she's not
completely irresponsible in that way and
she was quite happy to take on Theon and
Yara and speak to them on the level you
know I don't think she would expect that
from John but I think it's something he
might make
of his own accord a decision that he
might make in which case he's going to
need and a dream team what do we think
about that I think I lead every [ __ ]
chicken in this room I agree I mean I
agree that he will need a dream team to
catch a light do you think John would be
willing to lay down his titles to get
this help and say look I'm willing to
give up my title as king in the north
for you to help me do you think that
could convince Daenerys absolutely yeah
yeah I yeah he's some he'll do whatever
it takes and if that's what it takes
um I'm not sure Daenerys will expect
that from him but if she did he would do
that yeah that would be kind of shocking
for somebody to be willing to give up
that title especially I mean John didn't
necessarily want to be king but he did
want to be respected and for him to be
willing to do that to someone he just
met for the first time I think it would
be pretty clear that what he's saying is
the truth oh yeah point that would
convince him okay so when John leaves
Dragonstone Kyle do you think that this
alliance will be formed
will John leave and hemic Daenerys be on
good terms at this point are we in
episode 5 or 6 at this point pretty late
probably yeah because I think well I
mean he gets at Dragonstone Episode
three early episode three they leave
Dragonstone
at this late episode four maybe episode
five early episode five yeah I have to
think so man because we only got seven
episodes right and I think the wall has
to fall and I think John Elyse has to be
near or watching it happen
so I think that before that happens I
think he knows how important it is to
get Daenerys his army her army is
absolutely massive we have the unsullied
let's say part of the wall just falls
down and there's like a battle of
thermopylae type scenario they argue
we train to fight in that sort of style
the Phalanx so I mean obviously the
night King can just reanimate the dead
but certainly they would be helpful
they haven't fought in wintry conditions
but I mean the sheer numbers of them is
is a big thing and I have to think that
John wouldn't be that irresponsible to
let any sort of political agenda decide
the fate of the realm essentially
because in the end if John is still
around
I think the Iron Throne is gone right
and that's what ultimately it comes down
to you
yeah Daenerys wants the Iron Throne but
I think he's going to make her believe
it like seriously
yeah the Iron Throne is all good and
dandy but we say dandy here in Canada so
get get with that people buy it
yeah I think that you know obviously
he's he's going to be pretty convincing
and he's all he's all business at this
point I mean I mean he could have just
basically refused the call to go see
Daenerys and they're like you know I got
other stuff to deal with you go deal
with King's Landing he's making the time
to go down there and speak with her and
let her know what's going on and John is
a pretty intelligent guy and and Tyrion
knows that John is a true it's truthful
and John came from nothing so I think
that he would give up his titles I mean
I don't think that the titles matter to
him Cameron had previously referenced
that that that would happen so yeah I
think that I think that it has not that
it will happen it has to happen for the
storage progress yeah I totally agree I
know if I was John as soon as I left
Dragonstone if I had you know a boat or
ship full of dragonglass I would get all
of that up north and I would manned the
entire wall all those old castles along
the wall that are no longer being manned
I would get every swinging dick that I
had and those castles on top of that
wall armed with the dragon glass what do
you think about that do you think he's
going to do something like that when he
leaves Dragonstone do you see him
manning the wall as soon as possible
knowing that that breath is getting
closer and closer to the wall um I think
he does that before he leaves Winterfell
because in the books he has relinquished
those castles to Stannis and he started
like he gave one to two
Normand so he's already started manning
those castles and i think that for the
show i think it will stay on that same
course because that's the first line of
defense is the wall so the wall needs to
be fully full capacity full capacity on
the wall I would want enough men on that
wall to where they could all stretch
their arms out and they could be
touching everybody along the entire wall
I agree what do you think secrets is he
gonna man the wall ASAP yeah absolutely
like great said he's doing this in the
book just before the Nights Watch gold
star beyond him and he was yeah he was
getting everybody into position he
doesn't have the men as much as he would
like to do that but he was he was doing
the best he can the question is so I
mean you know we've been deciding
whether Daenerys is going to believe him
does she need proof but what about the
northern men if he's trying to get them
to man the wall I mean they're the only
army he's got they're the only forces
he's got so where is he going to ask
them to go to the wall are they going to
do that are they going to be cool with
joining blue watch you know taking the
black and I think that might be another
issue for him he's just gonna have
hurdle after hurdle after hurdle he's
going to need proof yeah that's a good
point because I think it was one of the
men from the Knights of the Vale right
before or after the king of the north
scene John was telling them about the
threat and about the winner and one of
them men I believe was from the Knights
of the Vale he said we should all go
home and just wait out the storm and
John said the knight King brings the
storm [ __ ] you can't sit at
home and wait this thing out like we
need to come together and prepare for
this so like you said secrets are they
going to be willing to do this that's
the question I think he totally has I
think a house is Manderley Kerwin and
Glover will do whatever he commands them
to do so if they have men
how's manually has a lot I think he has
the third largest army in the north so I
think he can help him out I also think
the wildlings will help them out and
also Spanish had some stray army up in
the north that kind of deserted him so
maybe they might seek refuge at the wall
and John has also asked what's her name
Rickard Karstark daughter I forget her
name we but he's Elise Elise he's asked
her to send men to the wall and she's
agreed to do that so that's in the books
so I don't I think that's going to play
out because I think she was casted this
for this season so that might actually
play out yeah I agree I think we're
definitely going to see that part come
into play up north when John leaves
Dragonstone where is he gonna go next
back to Winterfell for sure I mean I
imagine that John is not going to go to
King's Landing
perhaps he goes to the Riverlands and
they try to get a larger army I think
that obviously he knows he needs as many
many as he can get for the war for the
dawn the Nights Watch
only has how many people up like thirty
people the last time we saw them yeah
maybe
dollar a said I mean he's a great dude
but I don't think he can man the wall
against the White Walkers I just don't
think they simply have enough people and
and Greg you you're doing I believe the
nice Kings army in your next video I'm
not mistaken how big it is yep
and you maybe want to give a little
preview for that on how large you think
it might be I think Daenerys has more
than him woo okay that's four that's a
spicy nugget i I was I was gonna think
that you think the nice king's army is
bigger but yeah I mean I think I don't
think that John would be going very far
mister talking Thrones I think that John
would want to get right back to
Winterfell and like Jemma said he's
laser-focus so getting to Dragonstone
getting that dragon blast getting that
dragon glass using little fingers
jetpack back to Winterfell does
everybody agree with that you think he's
going to head right back to Winterfell
yeah he's going back to Winterfell
they what's he gonna do when he gets
there what do you think
make sure Littlefinger hasn't taken over
the world
huh
hey five episodes that [ __ ] could yeah
what do you say gray he heading back to
Winterfell right away or is he going to
go to the wall back to Winterfell uh
well actually he might this is what he
might do he might take a ship from
Dragon film to eastwatch-by-the-sea and
maybe drop some people off there check
on the situation there check on the
Nights Watch and then come back down to
Winterfell
so do you think this season's going to
end with Jon Snow being in Winterfell
yes he will he's going to be in
Winterfell in the crypts with bran and
then they're going to just zoom in on
Liana's a statue and cut us off and let
us chew on our fingers for another year
man that'll be so fantastic if they do
that let me ask somebody this because
it's kind of hard to ignore this so many
spoilers have came out and a report came
out that Jon Snow and some other people
were filming in Iceland and whenever
they film in Iceland those scenes are
always north of the wall does anybody
think Jon Snow is going to go north of
the wall next season I think we need to
get Gemma's opinion we need to hear her
luscious voice come on Gemma sees it
this is the thing with these these
spoilers when they first came out I mean
I haven't done a video on these either
because I have read them but just this
is a spoiler you know when you're not
caught up for you you haven't seen it
yet and somebody's talking about it or
that's a spoiler then there's a spoiler
when somebody creates a theory and it
turns out to be a correct theory that's
spoiler and then was spoiling it you
know just just outright spoiling it and
that's a different kind of spoiler and
that's not one I'm on board with but
he's got to go and get proof whether
we've asked for it or whether he's just
decided that he needs to go and get it
for Daenerys for the northern men he
needs if he doesn't if he can't prove if
he can't convince Westeros then then he
screwed and and he has to convince
everybody he has to make sure
everybody's on the same page and really
I can only see one way he could do that
and that is to show them they need to
see and how do you think he does that
then are you agreeing with some of the
reports they came out that John goes and
captures a white to bring itself is that
what you're thinking he could do yeah
I'm thinking ultimately that's what is
going to need to do when Alliser thorne
took that hands to King's Landing it's
rotted it
it was withered away to nothing it
wasn't crawling around anymore and I
mean winters here now so maybe it would
last a little bit longer but I think
he's going to need something a little
bit more tangible than a hand in a jar I
think they need a live specimen yeah
that's a good point that winner is now
here because a lot of people have been
up in debate about this whether or not
John could actually get a white that for
South without it rotting away but like
he said winter is here it's going to be
a hell of a lot colder the north is
going to be blanketed in snow so he
could travel that thing a pretty good
distance and keep it preserved let's
just say this I've had a quite a few
cups of shade of the - II and I think
that yes it's going to happen me and you
have had many discussions about these
leaks I don't know man there's something
about what mists and eight Natalie
Emanuel said when these first came in
what she is pretty miffed even though
she's my future wife I forgive her but
yeah I think for for things to really
move forward
one has to have a couple more meetings
versus the night king so I think that
they'll have an initial stare down again
we have benjin that's north of the wall
I mean they brought him back last season
we can have an interaction there
maybe there's wildlings that are still
left they can still be saved who knows
man but I think that ultimately Jon's
destiny is north of the wall we're in
the north
obviously the wall is going to fall at
some point but I do think he's going to
be north of the wall this season I do
actually believe that that white
scenario is going to be a thing so I'm
on board with that if we go with all the
spoiler photos we've seen John is with a
hell of a cast of players heading north
so if Jon were to go north of the wall
to try and capture a white he's
definitely taking the type of people you
would need to do that I actually believe
he will do it I don't know if he's going
to be successful
I can't guarantee he's actually going to
get a white South but I think he will
attempt it will they be 13 from all
together there has to be the last hero
with the 13th Commander of the Nights
Watch it that's how many figures the
night's king had the night King had
behind him when he turned the baby there
was the main guy and then there was his
12 companions yeah like his 12 disciples
didn't the last hero have 11 companions
in a dog or a hound yeah he did have a
dog I believe yeah so so ghost plus Jon
plush Sandor Davos you know like the
main cripples bastards and broken things
that are left in the story yeah pretty
much
I agree with that I great kids I think
if you catch a light how do you get it
through the wall because the wall has
magic in it I think he takes it around
like in a ship yeah so then he would
have to take a ship to there from
dragons film
yeah I think John see all of you said
he's going to stop at Winterfell with
soon as he leaves Dragonstone but I'd
actually disagree I think he's going to
lead Dragonstone and go straight to the
wall I think he might send out some
Ravens from Dragonstone unless he sends
tormund to the wall before he leaves I
think when he leaves Dragonstone he
could get word to his men hey she don't
believe us we got to get proof meet me
at the wall yeah I think I'm alone on
those same lines I I don't want them to
go catch away because I don't either
those are some of my favorite characters
on that roster on that Suicide Squad if
the Hound dies we write it but just to
still want to Kyle's quotes if they do
go beyond the wall to try to capture a
white with this group of characters it's
going to be pure straight gasoline
mm-hmm I'm glad I got you on that one
everybody's going to be saying it's
going to be one of those new hit words
that's trending from a Canadian no less
ha ha
I just realized I said live specimen and
of course I mean on dead specimen I just
like to clear that's what that one else
that's all right
I believe that's exactly how it was
worded in the plot leaked I think it
said live specimen so secrets let me ask
you this do you think John's going to be
successful and getting this white self
oh absolutely
he's then he'll get it he'll get what he
you went to go and get and but it's
going to come a really heavy price and
so what he got is 11 disciples and his
dog his direwolf and then are all coming
back not not by a long stretch and I
think Brienne maybe and the Hound
perhaps and it's very concise thoughts
of Mia going if they they're not a
chance that they come back because I
mean Barrick said in the books anyway
it's not looking good for Brienne in the
book so and it's not looking good for
the Hound in the books either so you're
basing on that I think none of them
coming back sorry Kyle big news do you
want to challenge there Kyle do you
think the Hound dies up there I would
like to challenge Jemma of the house
secrets to a trial by combat sorry
the hounds getting it it's some toast
brown bread everybody watch everybody
that watches this video I want you to
revolt in the comment section at this
absolute cluster [ __ ] that's going on
in this friggin podcast right now this
is absolutely absurd the Hound will not
die
I think the hounds gone I think
everybody that goes with him is gone
except for Gendry John himself and Jorah
even though I don't even know if Jorah
will make it I personally I don't think
Brienne is going to go but I do think
Thoros and barrack will definitely die
just like secret said I don't see them
coming back benjin will probably die I
do see him going full white if he isn't
already I mean we still don't know
benjin's full intentions he might be
sending a brain through the wall
purposely to bring it down benjin's eyes
aren't blue but we don't really know his
intentions what do you think about that
grey what do you think about benjin can
he die can't like can he die does he
need like dragonglass who did any dragon
blaster kill him because he have to be
killed a special way because technically
he's dead yeah he said the children did
put the dragon glass through his heart
just like the night king so yeah I'm not
sure about that I would really like to
see benjin like be able to come through
the wall with John and help him I
actually think benjin is going to go for
white or white Walker whatever you want
to call it and I think at some point
John's gonna have to put him down
that was my prediction oh that would
break John's heart it really would I
mean that would be awful
well yeah I can see that happening - I
dunno I've never thought about that one
yeah you've really given me a bit of
food for thought there and it would
absolutely break John's heart or all
he's ever thought I think throughout the
books you know years after benjin goes
missing he still holds out hope even to
the point where he knows he's being
stupid but you know the relationship
that he had with benjin was a really
special one and wow that would be really
really sad yeah absolutely I mean can
you imagine that
seeing your uncle for the first time in
years and he's now another and then you
have to basically decide am I going to
allow him to kill me or my men or am I
going to have to stop him that would be
a tough decision but you know what
decision you'd have to make you'd have
to put him down
yes and John always makes the decision
that has to be made no matter how
difficult it is he makes that decision
if he needs to you'll do what needs to
be done well and we look back to one of
the very first meetings between benjin
well when he came back to Winterfell he
told John about love and then John
embraced each area when he was north of
the wall so I think that that particular
conversation you don't know what you
would be missing will be really strong
for him because you would have to kill
Benjamin and he absolutely loves his
uncle he's very close to him gray what
do you think about that do you think
there could come a point to where John
would have to decide it would be
heartbreaking to see that but he has
always throughout his whole life had to
make difficult decisions so I don't
think it's going to change in season 7 I
think he's going to have a lot of
difficult decisions to make and while I
don't necessarily believe that that is
going to happen I think it's possible
it's very possible to happen I think
it's actually poetic if he has to do
that I don't know if poetic is the right
word because it would be heartbreaking
but that's what george RR martin and
that's what Danny days that's what they
like to do to us they like to build us
up and break our heart absolutely so
where does everybody seeing John end up
at the end of season seven like where do
we see him at in the last episode what
do you think he's doing is he down south
showing off this white did he already do
that he's back at Winterfell we're back
at the wall where do you think he's
going to be at Kyle when we see him for
one last time next season I think he is
going to be in the crypts of Winterfell
when the Horn of winter blows and the
walls going to fall it's going to make a
really really nasty sound and that's
going to be the moment where John was
about to interact with the Leanna's we
had a statue in the crypt and then
that's really going to start to take
things up we're going to see parts of
the wall fall and then we're just going
to hear this big noise that's that's my
tinfoil so I think John's actually going
to be in the crypts of Winterfell after
returning from his destination of
Dragonstone and it's going to be really
crazy because he's gonna be down the
crypts of winter phone here this like
loud loud noise I think all the Westeros
will hear it I think it's going to get
me yeah I agree I do think everybody's
going to hear it I think it's going to
be like a massive earthquake that you
know sends shockwaves across that entire
continent what does everybody else think
about John where his last scene will be
what do you think secrets you know what
what you are both just saying there that
gave me absolute shivers I can totally
visualize that that would be amazing and
I agree it's going to be heard all over
Westeros when that thing comes down and
I've seen I've read a lot about this
I've read a lot of theories and ideas
that I do a lot of research for my
videos and and quite a few people have
suggested that it doesn't have to come
down like a whole big crash and it could
just be a crack or it could just be a
portion but you are not going to build a
wall a fantasy wall into your text to
not have it crashed down dramatically
why would you why would it just be a
little whisper when it could be an
absolute firestorm and that would be
amazing
apparently if you are on the height
power in all town you can actually see
the wall it is that big so it will be
heard and I think we'll get a shot not
just a job but all the characters
looking up and hearing that no matter
where in all the different locations for
King's Landing Dragonstone wherever they
are they're all going to hear that and
shit's going down I agree with what
Jemma said because if you think about it
there's supposedly this George Orman I
know I'm going to butcher the name
Germans horn Norman Norman Norman
somebody how does it pronounce German
isn't it spot-on German okay that horn
it said to bring down the wall or to
wait sleeping giants or something like
that but if you think about how massive
that collapse would be of the wall it
would probably be so massive that it
might cause like catastrophes it might
affect the Oh like an earthquake and it
might cause a really bad storm like at
sea just from like the actual it could
be actual seismic activity related to
that wall and just if there was anything
that was going to wake giant surf there
was any Giants to be awakened then it
would be if that wall crashes down
they're going to be awake if they were
sleeping they're up now possibly even
the kings of winter do not even get me
started on the kings of winter did not
even go there at the fair of the fake
news being chanted repeatedly over what
I'm trying to say here I'm calling it
right now those dead kings and the
crypts of Winterfell are coming they are
coming and they are going to be John's
army and this is my tin foil and they
are going to rise from their cold black
graves
stumbling and John snow will be in the
crypts
and he'll be like you know like can you
put an undead army well snap how's that
this message was endorsed by gray area I
agree I agree with secret that sounds
phenomenal actually John's dead or
undead army however you want to look at
it against the makings I would love that
I hope we get to see that on the screen
actually that would be amazing
so like Aragorn and more of the Rings
type deal is that way exactly
nice I'm in Kyle Kyle [ __ ] chicken
endorses this message is there anything
else anybody wants to add to this like
before we go is there any other
scenarios you can see John's no end
before the end of the season Kyle do you
want to add anything I think that the
shift from King's Landing to the north
will be a significant one this season
obviously we will still get some stuff
in King's Landing but I think the big
event was the Sept of Baelor blowing up
I think that's the big the big moment
other than the red key being destroyed
at some point by the White Walkers if
they get there but I do think I did
think we're in for a couple shocking
hold the door moments the least didn't
say that Arya and John would meet back
again but how could they not do that
they get really going to make us wait I
think that John and I are going to meet
again next season and it's going to make
me cry like a small child I could be
your family oh my god I can't wait for
that I'm on the same page with Kyle
besides what we already talked about I
think that there's going to be two more
things that we haven't talked about that
are going to happen there he's gonna
reunite with Arya I think in Episode
seven before he goes down to the crypts
he probably reunites with Arya and maybe
bran
but I also think he's going to have a
risk with Sansa I think him and science
are going to be at odds most of season
seven can I comment on this I am
absolutely in disagreement with this
statement but I do above gray area
yeah I can't say I agree with that
either there might be a little tension
between them too but John's going to be
gone for so long like he's going to be
in Dragonstone for several episodes and
I think he's going to be north and north
of the wall for several episodes then we
may even see him do this parlay scene in
King's Landing I'm still not sure I'm
still not sold on that one but I just
don't think we're going to get a lot of
scenes with songs and Jon together to
see too much of this bumping of heads I
have my I agree and I feel that Sansa
will be having poisoned dripped into her
ear via Littlefinger throughout the
course of the season so there will be a
kind of odds with John but John might
not necessarily be there to be aware of
what's going on because obviously his
focus is elsewhere and so I think it's
going to be up to Sam's own area to deal
with Littlefinger I have faith I think
fans is going to come good I know not
many people agree but I'm holding out
hope that Sam's is going to finally once
do the right thing I agree I agree that
that Littlefinger is going to be in her
ear and I think what will cause the
biggest risk between her and Jon I mean
they might be in different locations it
might happen through Ravens like I don't
know but if he bends the knee I don't
think she's going to be happy about it
because I think she's going to feel like
we've done all of this stuff we fought
for our home back your King in the north
we're no longer under the rule of any
southern Kings and you go and do this
that's a very good point I didn't even
think about that
if saunter does get news that John bent
the knee then yeah I could definitely
see her having a problem with that
absolutely especially him bending the
knee to another woman I could absolutely
see that I think Jon his whole story
this season is going to be choices like
difficult
voices like what if Daenerys says the
only way I'll join your army or I'll do
like what if she has stipulations other
than just him bending the knee what if
she requires him to make marriages of
his sister's - to Tyrion or to not grey
worm my god but Jorah or someone like
you know that's how alliances are made
so there has to be some kind of marriage
she might have terms behind this
alliance I like that idea actually and
if that does happen
hopefully it's Tyrion and Sansa in my
opinion what about and beyond well
beyond kind of team Targaryen now isn't
me so you know and I'm trying to think
who would she sell off by a marriage I
mean yeah there's going to be an issue
with beyond producing an heir but I
can't really think of me she's got no
family there's no one else well she does
have family but I think there's going to
be a marriage but I don't think it's
going to be happening with Jana or
anything like that or with any esteemed
Targaryen I think that's going to be in
King's Landing with senior on
I don't think Jon's going to be getting
married next season things could change
by season aid but I don't see him wife
and anybody up by the end of next season
he's just got too much [ __ ] to do now if
he was forced to if he had no choice
then maybe but I don't know I mean
Daenerys did say you know she could
possibly get married again so we really
don't know how that's going to play out
I know everybody ships most not
everybody because I don't know you guys
opinion on this but a lot of people ship
John and Danny and a lot of people want
to see that happen next season
personally I do not want to see that
happen no no I don't want to see that
happen I really don't want to see that
happen I don't want to see it either but
as somehow think that that might happen
I think that season 7 is going to be the
best season of television ever
so really what's going to happen is we
we had some news kimono Watchers on the
wall the other day Mike Reyes said that
if we thought that bowel the bastards
was big that pales in comparison to
season 7 and season 8 stuff so I think I
think that we're in for some major major
major stuff and I think that another
battle with the White Walkers is going
to happen but this time we're going to
see Jon fight the night's king at some
point to season oh [ __ ] you think John's
going to fight the night king one verse
one I think it's definitely possible I
think he's going to fight a white Walker
1,000% next season and I think he's
gonna and and this time he's I think
that he's going to be so pissed off with
what is happening we're really going to
see the fire side of John come out this
season like I said the natural evolution
of John is for him to adopt more of his
fireside and then have a balance of it
by the end I think that we're gonna like
John's going to go a little bit berserk
like Wolverine kinda and lose his mind a
little bit because we do know that that
changed him a lot I mean he saw what was
really up you know what I mean just the
darkness that's not a good thing
and he's still here and a lot of people
aren't jamming with what he's doing so
he's trying to be effective in
everything he's doing so I think that
when he sees things aren't going right
he's is gonna you can be really pissed
off but it's kind of it's going to turn
a lot of women on like Gemma and gray
they're going to be like drinking lots
of wine when this happens I drink lots
of wine anyway I saw that glass you had
it's like at least 76 ounces that's what
were you saying about don't anything
though I mean did he really I mean like
very some Darion and I know he's died a
lot more times but he tell me look his
memories gone the physical parts of him
are gone he's he's an absolute shadow of
his former self with with the singular
mission of his will only last living
memory and I was expecting more of a
change in John in season six when he
came back
and yeah it was there and it was subtly
did things that he probably wouldn't of
them before and but Biddy change as much
as you expect them to because I expected
something I'd know more dramatic clap
well I've been saying John is going to
dodge his fireside and I think we're
going to get a flashback and I do
laughing tree me Ana's pretty fiery for
for wolf wild wolf he is the white wolf
you think you think the guy they're
going to make that connection this
season I mean that's a big part of his
story right I mean ultimately I don't
think you'll find out until sees me it's
like a big Luke Skywalker type moment
like hey ladies yes sir you've been
kissing her I mean but this is huge you
think that that that these hands they're
going to keep on dropping these since
the season like this got to be a big
thing right I think he's already fiery I
think most of who he is is his stark
blood like I don't I think we need to
see more Rhaegar then Leone I think
that's what we see all the time is Liana
and that's what we've seen the whole
show because throughout everything Jon
has always been compared to Arya Jon has
always been a start even when he ranges
beyond the wall Craster as soon as he
sees him says you had the look of a
stark so not just in his looks like in
his action of how much honour he has and
how much I don't know I don't know where
I was going but not just in his action
not just in his looks but in his action
like him dedicating his life to the to
saving the realm but he could be really
selfish right now and just like drink
and just chill out and just let winter
come and kill everyone he could be
really selfish like that but he's trying
to fight for everyone and I said I just
think we've always seen lianna we need
to see some Rhaegar
yeah I completely agree with that I
would love to see that side of him come
out more and maybe we could see that
when he is around other Targaryen like
Daenerys or maybe when he's around these
dragons perhaps that's when we can
really start to see this Targaryen side
of John's start to come out I agree and
that and I think even even him being
able to touch the dragon because I think
he will be able to touch it even him
being able to touch it and like right
away he might not think anything of it
but later he might start putting things
together like things together in his own
mind like why was I able to touch this
dragon because I'm sure she might say
something I'm sure she might say like my
dragons usually don't let people touch
them or stuff like that season seven we
waited a long time and as much as much
as Dan and Dave get criticized I think
this season is going to be absolutely
fantastic if we're looking at the model
from Breaking Bad for their last two
seasons and Game of Thrones is following
that model we can expect the hell of
this season so I think that everyone
that listens to this video you know and
supporters of the golden company we're
going to have a lot more of this coming
for you guys Wow I'm just I'm
overwhelmingly excited I think that
everyone else should be and I think this
the final focus of magic dragons and
really the coming together of of the
realm is is going to be like the return
of the king and where the rings look
better on television over 13 episodes so
give that up give that a little taste
I think season 7 is going to be awesome
and what I think is even going to be
more awesome is that we're going to be
live-streaming after every episode and
having breakdowns and predictions and
just going crazy yeah I'm really looking
forward to that it's going to be
fantastic
we're all going to come together and
it's going to be chaos because some holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] moments are going to
land and we'll have this wonderful
script and we're going to do it like
this and then something's going to
happen and it's just going to be a
free-for-all it's going to be alright
laughs we're going to have a lot of fun
so make sure you come and join the
golden company abs
lutely I agree with everything you all
just said I can't wait for season seven
it's going to be epic now that all the
main cast and characters are going to be
crossing paths with each other things
are going to get very exciting and also
can't wait to record with all of you and
discuss all the episodes during this
upcoming season but before we sign off
what all of you like to say your
goodbyes yes absolutely
I've been Gemma from secrets of the
Citadel have a great day and I'll see
you in the next one thanks for joining
us guys it's great area and I'll see you
next time yeah
very fun time Dan thank you for having
me great great great
talk finally got to collab with the
golden company let's do it again soon
thank you all so much for coming on
we're actually going to be doing another
video together and it's going to be over
on secrets of the citadel's Channel and
it's going to be about Cersei Lannister
so definitely be looking forward to that
definitely keep your eyes open for that
and we'll see you guys on the next one
bye